I recently got an email from a mom and
dad who wanted me to know just how
extraordinary their eight-year-old
daughter Riley is they said she
constantly shows quiet kindness I love
that quiet tightness whether it's
befriended a new classmate or defending
and comforting a kid who's being bullied
I knew I wanted to meet Riley so I
brought her here along with her parents
Selina and Matthew she has a birthday
coming up so we really wanted to
celebrate it in a bigger way make it
special dad's birthday we're throwing a
frozen party I hear you like frozen
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
before you go though Chloe has something
special for you I think right I think
it's over here she brought it out at the
beginning of the show to you an earful
of delicious possibility
the mood it's held you will murder you
Kelly
thank you so much subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going